Lillith way outside knocks down the
first ring from long-range to start
again look at the shot this is starting
the ballgame look how far he was and
this is a great screener and roller good
pass by Westbrook running start by girl
respect little it says it's like two
dogs fighting the way they go at each
other McCallum gets his first look
really short roll pocket pass right here
and this is where Cantor's lack of link
really hurts him he was back in front of
Adams good ball movement here McCullum
back out Lilly checks the three-point
line now see Westbrook to the basket
first field goal first points for
Russell Westbrook
George stolen by Lillard
Westbrook Clemson Westbrook for three
bound the head of steam down the court
plays it up and he hung up the floor
after dread in the rebound in about four
seconds we'll get to the nicking of
defense and make a play gets all the way
to the cup and finishing on the baseline
for first landfall sweet move from
Damien Lillard fifth rebound to go on
with six points and six assists drives
inside quick move left handed Russell
what Stella first half allow his team to
climb back into this ball game over enes
kanter Lillard again long distance from
downtown I don't know how you guard out
the thirty feet thunders defense has
really gotten good this quarter nice
feed inside and George finally sees one
go through the roof comes one who's Mark
mentioned scoreless since that first
water falling away there it goes
three players in double figures for the
Blazers Kanter and the backcourt
Westbrook drives and finishes because
it's the elephant in the room we need to
discuss it get past it as Westbrook with
another finish but on the fact that we
we fell short of algo
[Applause]
[Music]
Lillard goes hard at Adams bad shot
Lillard gets to his favored left-hand
Park Lass's the next guy he's just split
Portland's tremblers has picked him up
certainly was newtrich out with valuable
addition is Westbrook knocks that one
day
[Applause]
Willard that's good for this superstar
point gone Dane dollar shout out
congratulations to the legend Tiger
Woods
another green jacket spectacular job
Westbrook back sit on Trudeau chasing
Lillard move on the back stops tough
shot the paint bounces around the rabbit
drops in and a win on the road despite
an abysmal performance from three-point
range
West Coast banks it on the rhythm you
get Westbrook going to the basket Adams
on the roll trying to get Portland going
Lillard slacking off over
Lillith allows him to shoot the
basketball he must not know the rules
hand down man down this is bad defense
he's worried about the other Lillard all
over him rest up on the crowd early
they have a past
aside from their great talent it's what
makes it most interesting as well these
two go at each other as hard as any two
opponents in the NBA timeout on the
floor yeah you know the playoffs have
arrived especially when Westbrook and
Lillard are involved and it's the
largest lead of the game
Lillard this is terrific pursuit by
Westbrook
to stay in the play not to stop
then spikes it out about stay in the
play not to stop and then spikes it out
about you can owner said if it's mucking
up the whole game the way they've played
so physical basketball from the opening
tap Vantage of the smaller Damion Lillet
no he'll gets the contact and the bass
pushing up to 16 Portland cut it down to
five and if that's up to 12 is Larry
walks the other way that's gonna be a
world town
scheme has really gone up a couple of
notches and it was New Orleans no well
load offense Westbrook well falling away
but you one-on-one get to your spot
backs in the smaller Lilla elevates
knocks it down tells the baby go sleep
shorter pass deflected ran back out
Westbrook Westbrook for three
look at this event he never taken he
said you know when I said I talked about
using every bit of the shot clock
how about this by Russ as he continues
well you see the intensity there
[Applause]
[Music]
a chance to send the Thunder home
Willard long-range three
[Applause]
[Applause]
dagger oh my goodness
to put them out he went 4/5
that was forty seven forty eight nine
and fifty points on that was that's
amazing
Oh five years ago
hit up three against your rocket yes to
win the first round series
[Applause]
50 points
[Music]
goodnight Oklahoma City sees it over